need you to be our quarterback DeRozan
told me today I'd shoot around it was
disappointing but he's not looking back
in today though DeRozan is on the board
alley with showings LeBron James who
answered with a bucket on the interior
sequence for the Raptors their offensive
Hoffman sends him down to James jeans
jumper in the circle
Lowery has six assists for Toronto and
no turnovers Raptors are 6 of 8 from the
field in the second quarter games
tension to the round potential team with
their smart spin dribble James
there's some tough minutes because
nagira
to come in and try and stop this hot cat
off balance and a tough angle for LeBron
j4 / sets the street on an Adobe James
[Applause]
Hill Jordans on the baseline sets up
James for the easy bucket and left open
for Mississippi James LeBron James James
with Seattle
James confession yes felt like this
could be their year the things that
clicking James
[Applause]
our Lowrey having to change their games
behind the offensive stylings of Nick
nurse and then adopt adopting a new way
to play